our announcer george takei
we've known him now from star trek he
was commander sulu we've had him on the
show a million times and everybody loves
george and everybody loves his husband
brad you call him his by his final uh
rank uh commander
commander commander takei yes
of course i do
i didn't know you did that george takei
was the grand marshal
of the first japan day parade in new
york city so you could imagine you know
i'm the grand marshal commander schuler
does that come with a uniform
we thought this was a good opportunity
to touch base with george and bread so
we sent our crack team memet and derek
to cover the big day
the day before the parade george went on
the view he was a guest on the view and
he was there to promote the event
but the interview took a turn as it
sometimes will and and here's a little
clip from the view when i
turn 9 and
10 and 11.
i
sense that i was different from the
others
bobby corral
had the sweetest smile
or
richard
he montana very athletic
and and his mother didn't uh buy new
clothes for him
i grew up in east alley
all mexican-american barrio and when
uh richard montana hunkered down to play
marbles his tight t-shirt
went up and his tight pant jeans
crept down and i saw a little bit of the
small of his back okay it was very
exciting so i grew up knowing i was
different right right you know what's
great about george he does our show and
when he talks about you know seeing some
guy's ass crack yeah that's we let it go
we love it right on the view they're
still pretending like this is a horrible
thing to say i know i could hear that
somebody wanted to pull in the reins
they did they were like how far is this
going to go well they encouraged them
he's on the view and then all of a
sudden he said you know i i was
attracted to bobby and i and everyone
goes
and then he goes he sees he's getting
laughs and he goes and then i saw his
ass crack and then oh
yeah
anyway that interview led to a marital
spat between george and brad oh really
yeah they told us about it when we
arrived at the apartment the next day we
had a fight yesterday
we rarely fight george
feels honored and privileged to be the
grand marshal the japan parade is
organized by the government of japan and
so it's like when george starts talking
about
the
butthole or butt crack clean that hole
you know it's kind of like
the poor government of
this is our japan
and
that got me upset hey mamet he's got
some life huh
it's great it's fascinating i mean
there's a reality show in this don't you
think brad and george yeah
oh yeah for sure it's a really it's a
definitely it's an interesting dynamic a
lot of um
i would say passive aggressive kind of
behavior towards each other
right but um the parade in general was
just a
kind of a mess i felt sorry for george i
just felt he was a little disrespected
by the way the parade went down
so after george met with the consul
general
george was rushed off to the
ribbon-cutting ceremony george sat in a
fancy convertible for the parade route
and was soaking up the attention from
the crowds and his adoring fans and he
kept saying it started good he was put
in a convertible there were lots of fans
outside and everyone was very very
excited to see him so so far in the
parade things are going well and he kept
saying the same two phrases over and
over again live long and prosper
enjoy the parade
live long and prosperous this is a great
day for a parade
enjoy the parade
live long and prosper live long and
prosper live long and prosper
it's a beautiful day for a parade all
right so now this is where it starts to
go to [ __ ] the parade yeah this is great
for some reason
they made george get out of his car this
beautiful convertible he was in and
waving to everyone and saying live long
and prosper right in the middle of the
parade route to do press interviews and
there's a whole mix up so the car
carrying george keeps driving down the
parade route without george
well it was so sad because the
convertible was like dignified and it
really has like a sort of grand marshall
grandness to it and then he's just put
in this tiny little pathetic golf cart
so here it is this is george now on the
golf cart
live long and prosper
i'm beaming i'm beaming
ironically he's not prospering he's been
demoted to a golf cart
sounds like he's riding on a lawn mower
anyway there's a glimpse into our hero
george takei in his big day as the
grand marshal as brought to you by mamet
and derek as they traveled
around with george and brad
live long and prosper it's a beautiful
day for a parade